Я не знаю, что это не только.
Оскар, что можешь сказать о Домитике?
Что можешь сказать о Домитике?
Я думаю, что это потому, что ты говоришь в английском, и это переводится в английском.
Я не знаю, что это работает.
Я написал мне сообщение, чтобы проверить, что это работает.
Я не знаю, что это на вашей части.
Оскар, это работает от моей стороны.
Я видел транскриптуру и услышал пространство от Оскар.
Я слышал все правильно, в начале.
Были небольшие интерференции, но потом я получил правильный сообщение с переводом от Оскар.
Сейчас я отправил два сообщения: один в русском, другой в английском.
Оскар, как вы видели эти сообщения?
В оригинале или были они в английском?
Я вижу, что первый сообщение split в два, где есть русский на праве,
и это автоматически переводится в английском на праве.
И вторая сообща будет просто английский на левом, но все осталось бы работать.
Все работает хорошо в этой части.
Поехали на пункт 8.
Это наш чат.
Мы оставим этот чат.
О, я думаю, мы закончили здесь.
Я не знаю, что это было, но я не знаю, что это было.
Да, я вижу транскрипцию от этого чата.
О, это очень хорошо.
Оскар, что ты можешь сказать о Дометти? Это работает от моей стороны.
Что ты думаешь о этой трансляции?
Как вы думаете об этом пространстве, пространстве и чат функций?
Я думаю, что они работали хорошо, я имею в виду, как ты говоришь, было немного длит.
В некоторых частях пространство работало очень хорошо, в том числе и чат функций.
Перфектно.
Так, без остановки, давайте перейдем к пункту 8.
Чат функций.
Командый чат.
Это на панели, с каналами, я думаю.
I opened the channels and I'm pressing the button "new channel".
I see that "new channel" selects from contacts, I don't have any contacts and I can't create a chat without any contacts.
I did see in the meetings earlier, when you're in a meeting, you can click on someone's profile and add them to your contacts, but I don't see anything to do with the user page.
Да, я тоже видела это.
Проблема есть, что я не вижу никакого контакта в аппарате.
Так что я не могу добавить никакого контакта.
Давайте попробуем это в митинге.
Но это немного комфортно.
Давайте обратно к митинге.
Примерно.
Да, я добавил Оскар в моем контакте.
Оскар, ты можешь сделать так же?
Я добавил Оскар в моем контакте, можно сделать так же?
Я пытаюсь создать канал с Оскаром, теперь я вижу что Оскар является моим контакт, я пытаюсь создать канал с Оскаром.
Я нажимаю кнопку, чтобы создать канал, я вижу что Оскар является моим контакт, теперь у меня есть канал с Оскаром.
Добавил субтитры DimaTorzok
один должен быть транскреплено в языке, и один должен быть в языке.
- Это работает perfectly. - Проверк.
- Вы можете сделать это? - Да, я вижу это в русском языке.
Окей, это немного вредно, чтобы открыть в Вик-экетчат.
So, next one, I'll try to paste any big text, maybe from Wikipedia to the chat.
Copy a big text from Wikipedia, I'll send it to the chat.
It's copy-paste right.
I see that comes right.
Alright, I'll send the same text on Russian.
So, do you see this text translated?
I see, I have a pop-up that message is too long for translate.
I see the message is too long for translate, maximum is 1000 characters, right?
And Oscar sees it in the original, right?
Yeah, I see the original English one.
Okay, let's try to use a button for join in our chat page, join the meeting.
I see the host responsibility, only the following members have access to the meeting with Oscar and me.
So the meetings work correctly, I also see, I also see, I also see, I also see, I also see that there are different new ideas.
And what else?
I see, that I need to make a note from the chat, note editor, that I need to make a note from the chat, note editor.
Сейчас нам нужно создать заметку из чата и попробовать ее отредактировать.
Также я вижу, что чат, который открывается во время созвона, такой же, как и во время нашего чата вне созвона, продолжился.
Я вижу кнопку создать записку, continued.
I see the button to create a note.
И открыл...
I opened it.
Оскар, попробуй найти заметку какую-нибудь,
если ты ее увидишь в чате.
Оскар.
Да, вот она.
Try to find a note of some kind, if you see it in the chat.
И...
Нотэнгу, нотэнгу.
Есть небольшие баги в чате при виде перевода. В некоторых местах он на русском, в некотором на английском.
Я услышал правильный перевод голоса Оскара, что это был хороший созвон.
Сейчас я удалю записку из чата, она должна пропасть также у Оскара.
Now I will delete the note from the chat, it should disappear from Oscars as well.
- It has disappeared. - Отлично.
Тогда заканчиваем этот созвон, переходим в Discord, с этой частью мы закончили.
- Then we finish this call and go to Discord with this part here. - Okay, we're done.
- It was, I think it's 7-8.